de la zumba pour s'échauffer les
lunettes de soleil sur la tête
l'ambiance estivale s'est déjà installé
à coignières ce samedi matin pour les
fous les couleurs en famille ou entre
amis près de 200 participants ont
franchi les nuages colorés des 2 km 200
du parcours c'est rigolo ça grâce ça
amuse les enfants s'amusent tout le
monde en plus la nature fait bien les
choses sa forme des coeurs avec la
transpiration et pathé mais ont su
ensemble on transpire en famille c'est
important on est tous enfin nous plus ou
moins et ça nous fait du bien il fait
beau on voit la vie non pas en rose mais
toutes les couleurs ça fait un peu
sortir se fait balader rencontrer des
jours se faire des amis et avoir plein
de couleurs sur soa et s'amuser du bleu
du vert de l'oranje avec cette poudre de
maïs colorer les habitants de coignières
en ont vu de toutes les couleurs
un événement organisé par le service
jeunesse en partenariat avec des
associations de la ville
le principe c'est de faire une matinée
tout à fait festive et sportive en même
temps qui est ouverte à tous les enfants
adultes grands-parents tout le tout
celle qui tous ceux qui veulent venir
faire un petit peu de sport marcher
ensemble le lancement de la période
estivale avec à l'horizon les grandes
vacances
la commune de coignières prépare déjà
une semaine d'activités prévues en
juillet pour les jeunes de la ville